bon vous avez votre dose de discours
alors on va essayer d'être très rapide
d'abord pour dire à Monsieur le Maire à
toute l'équipe municipale de Loudun
combien on est content de voir un pays
qui s'affiche avec le sourire aux lèvres
on ne gagne pas aujourd'hui dans la
bataille du développement en pleurs des
champs on va on gagne quand on est
capable de séduire quand on monte ses
forces quand on monte qu'on a envie
d'accueillir et qu'on a vraiment une
joie d'être ce qu'on est et de se
développer et cette fois c'est ça c'est
vraiment le loup du nez qui se présente
avec ses atouts avec ses capacités je
crois que ça c'est très important donc
merci à vous tous on sait sur le maire
que vous avez beaucoup de projets on est
heureux de voir ici un territoire
rassemblé et de voir tous ces élus ici
et quand je pense qu'il y en a moins un
sur deux qui a profit de discours vous
vous rendez compte à côté de quoi vous
avez
échapper bon alors d'abord je voudrais
on les saluant les uns les autres dire
combien il est important d'avoir un
département et je le dis ici devant
notamment Jean-Pierre rabelin parce que
non seulement il est le maire de
Châtellerault mais là jouer un rôle
structurant un peu avec sa ville dans
notre département il y a les conseillers
généraux Alain Bruno
Édouard winet Dominique Dominique
tout cela je pense que c'est très
important on a un bon modèle de
développement dans la Vienne on voudrait
nous faire croire que le modèle toute
urbain est bien meilleur au fond un
habitant sur deux habite à la campagne à
l'habitant sur deux habite dans la ville
nous avons un développement multi
polaire on a on a plein de petites
villes dans notre département regardez
Limoges Limoges fait 200000 habitants
ils sont passés de 100000 à 200 000 ils
ont tout bouffé tout autour
nous on a 100 000 habitants à Poitiers
et le reste se développe et donc c'est
ça qu'il faut faire il faut faire un
développement de la viande multi polaire
et de ce point de vue là le loup du nez
a besoin de Loudun et de sa force que le
pôle de développement de ce territoire
comme le siège a besoin de Civray comme
même à Chauvigny on a besoin de
Chauvigny
il me demande de le dire
systématiquement
c'est comme ça que j'ai la peine donc
c'est quand même très important d'avoir
ce pôle et ce pôle de loup du nez ici et
d'avoir une vision de la Vienne
multipolaire nous allons le renforcer ce
pôle notamment avec le Center Parc je
salue Marie-Jeanne Bel-Ami mère de trois
Moutiers qui a avec Dominique Créon
beaucoup travaillé sur ce projet
Dominique avec l'agence départementale
pour attirer ici une force économique
qui va être non seulement une force
d'image parce que votre territoire va
être à la télévision souvent donc il va
falloir le présenter donc attention à
l'environnement attention à l'image de
qualité attention à tout ce visage que
nous allons donner parce que c'est ça
qui va être la carte de visite du
territoire parce que ça va être très
structurant et puis derrière il y a
toutes les technologies qu'il y a dans
ce projet parce que non seulement il y
en permanence 5000 personnes qui
viennent c'est-à-dire autant de nuitée
au total que sur le Futuroscope c'est
dire un peu l'ampleur du sujet mais
aussi beaucoup de technologie sur
l'environnement sur la vie en ville sur
tout ce qui est aujourd'hui
l'espace durable que nous voulons pour
nos territoires et donc là il y aura des
projets de développement nous allons en
parler nous allons parler ce matin à la
mairie de Houdain avec Monsieur le Maire
et son équipe municipale il y a là un
potentiel de développement mais je crois
qu'on a franchi une étape très
importante et je suis vraiment heureux
que l'histoire fait que ce qu'était un
une stratégie de René Monory ce qu'il
nous a appris ce qu'il nous a montré
comme chemin finalement on va le faire
d'une certaine manière avec lui comme
quoi de temps en temps quand la
politique est grande elle est éternelle
et donc nous sommes sur ce sujet très
motivé nous avons aussi le souci dans ce
département d'aider les petites et
moyennes entreprises et les artisans
là je pense que il faut être clair et un
certain nombre de sujets qui pourraient
être très pratique pour relancer les
choses pour les PME faut bouger les
seuls sociaux quand vous revoyez le
nombre d'entreprises dans la Vienne
qu'on 49 salariés si vous mettez le
seuil de 50 à 100 vous allez voir on va
gagner de l'emploi et donc et ça ça
coûte rien à personne donc qu'on essaie
de le faire assez vite quand un
artisanat je pense puisque tout le monde
a parlé d'apprentissage j'ajoute qu'un
point sur ce sujet il faut que les
services de l'État arrête de considérer
l'artisan comme coupable quand il prend
un apprenti et de lui mettre en
permanence tous les contrôles toutes les
pressions comme si embaucher un apprenti
c'était un acte à la limite du droit et
donc en permanence on fait de celui qui
prend un apprenti un accusé quand il a
pris trois contrôles qui se fait
engueuler par tous les services et qu'à
un moment ou un autre on lui a tellement
compliqué la vie il prend plus
d'apprenti donc il faut que celui qui
donne de son temps pour former des
jeunes il soit considérait par la
société comme quelqu'un qui rend un
service public et donc il faut aussi le
considérer le respecter je pense qu'il y
a beaucoup de choses à faire qui coûtent
pas d'argent mais déjà si tout nos
services respectaient bien ceux qui se
consacrent à la formation notamment dans
l'artisanat et qu'on fait du maître
d'apprentissage quelqu'un qui est
porteur de valeur on en développerait et
vous verrez qu'apportable marcherait
mieux parce qu'aujourd'hui naturellement
on a le sentiment que pour un artisan
prendre un apprenti c'est se mettre dans
des circuits qui l'éloignent de son
travail plus que ça le développe et donc
là la question est souvent c'est par
l'humain qu'on règle les questions voilà
un certain nombre d'orientation que
cette fois peut nous inspirer mais au
total quand je vois la situation de
notre pays on est dans une situation
extrêmement grave d'abord je crois que
la tension internationale il faut bien
le mesurer est très préoccupante
aujourd'hui des troupes françaises sont
engagés en Irak sont engagés en Afrique
dans plusieurs théâtres d'opération on
sent la situation internationale
extrêmement préoccupante ce qui se passe
en Ukraine est aussi pour tout le
continent européen un sujet des grandes
préoccupations donc on voit que la
tension internationale n'a sans doute
jamais été aussi forte dans toutes ces
dernières années c'est à cela vous
ajoutez une situation économique
européenne et d'une certaine manière
mondiale extrêmement fragile on était il
y a quelques mois dans des espoirs de
relance mais on voit que aujourd'hui la
Chine est en train de freiner l'Asie est
en train de freiner les États-Unis ne
n’apportent pas les perspectives pour
espérer qu'il puisse apporter et
d'autres situations européenne y compris
allemande présente quelques fragilités
donc on se dit qu'on est dans un
environnement extérieur à nous-mêmes qui
est assez fragile on a des problèmes
franco-français majeurs mais nous sommes
dans un environnement international qui
n'est pas très facile et donc je pense
qu'il y a une ligne d'avenir il y a une
ligne perspective qu'il faut essayer
d'avoir pour notre pays mais qui jamais
la ligne jamais la route que nous
prenons moi je crois qu'il faut soutenir
ce qui marche il faut aider ce qui
marche or en permanence en permanence
dans notre société on fragilise ce qui
marche pour corriger ce qui marche pas
et au total ça finit par que rien ne
marche on a un certain nombre de
secteurs aujourd'hui quand vous regardez
bien nos modèles territoriaux est-ce que
vraiment il faut s'en prendre
aujourd'hui au territoire tel qu'ils
sont pour essayer de tout chambouler et
de couper les crédits des communes alors
qu'elles font 70% des investissements
publics ça marche vous mettez vous
donnez 5000 euros dans une équipe
municipale il vous trouveront le bout de
trottoir et vous trouveront l'activité
économique qui très vite transforme de
l'argent en emploi et dont ce qui marche
et arrêtons de juger l'artisanat jugé
l'épée ça marche et quand on a quelque
chose qui marche ça se protège et au
fond dans notre société on a qu'une idée
si ça pouvait
marcher autrement on a dans cher
ils avaient un syndicat d'eau donc on le
met dans un autre syndicat comme ça se
passe aussi dans le nord c'était quelque
chose qui marchait alors maintenant ils
sont pas contents de ça et maintenant il
y a des grèves pour boucler ça ça
marchait qu'on laisse ce qui marche et
qu'on s'attaque pas à tout ce qui marche
aujourd'hui vous avez des PME vous avez
des artisans on a une situation agricole
on est en train de mettre des
complexités à l'agriculture qui un jour
va faire et ça va pas être temps
longtemps qu'on va importer du lait en
France on va importer du lait dans ce
pays qu'attendent territoire ruraux
disponible et pourquoi ça et en
permanence on leur met des contraintes
elle marche notre agriculture on a la
meilleure traçabilité du monde on a des
on a des qualités exceptionnelles sur le
plan génétique pourquoi en permanence
leur maître des choses qui les empêchent
de travailler davantage ça marche et on
s'y attaque et on attaque partout dans
notre société ce qui m'a voilà le ce que
je voulais vous passer si seulement je
disais dans notre pays il y a des choses
qui marchent et bien écoutez nous on a
du bon sens on va d'abord défendre ce
qui marche et on va essayer de protéger
ce qui m'a parce que dans notre monde
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas capable de
protéger les atouts de la France et Dieu
sait s'il y en a des atouts de la France
si on n'est pas capable de les protéger
et si petit à petit ce sont les Français
qui s'attaquent aux atouts de la France
alors comment voulez-vous que dans un
monde de compétition on puisse s'en
défendre alors pour ça il faut être
attaché à son territoire et attaché à
ses entreprises elle t'a acheté un son
secteur économique avoir confiance avoir
confiance dans les agriculteurs vous
croyez qu'ils veulent empoisonner les
gens les agriculteurs vous croyez que
les artisans ils veulent emmerder les
apprentis on veut toujours soupçonner
les gens réagissent de vouloir nuire à
la société alors qu'il n'aspire qu'à une
chose c'est à se développer dans un
contexte qui marche donc c'est ça je
crois le message le plus important
aujourd'hui dans notre société regardons
le bon sens regardons ce qui fonctionne
et quand on a la chance d'avoir des
choses qui fonctionnent on les
accompagne plutôt qu'on les empêche j'ai
discuté avec un ami allemand récemment
qui disait tu sais t'inquiète pas en
Allemagne en Allemagne aussi il y a
qu'un Allemand sur deux qui veut
travailler
il y a un allemand sur deux qui veut
travailler et un allemand sur deux qui
veut pas travailler passer comme en
France il dit il y a peut-être une
différence chez nous
c'est pas comme chez vous chez vous
celui qui travaille pas il empêche qu'il
travaille de travailler bon je crois que
c'est un peu ça quand même faut qu'on
n'empêche pas les gens de travailler et
ceux qui travaillent ils font plutôt les
accompagner plutôt que de leur
compliquer la vie parce que le maire de
Loudun a dit quelque chose tout à
l'heure qui est très important c'est
l'emploi qui crée l'emploi c'est le
travail qui crée le travail et au fond
le travail ça s'ajoute plus que ça se
partage et donc c'est ça la vraie vérité
de l'action économique et ce dont nous
avons besoin aujourd'hui donc c'est un
peu ça le message de Loudun c'est qu'au
fond il y a des atouts à Loudun il y a
des inquiétudes mais appuyons-nous sur
les atouts appuyons-nous sur les forces
appuyons sur cette activité économique
qui est aujourd'hui mobilisée et si on a
confiance en nous vous verrez qu'on fera
face à toutes les difficultés et si
notre pays avait un peu confiance en lui
ont surmontré un grand nombre de
difficultés il y a un grand pape qui a
dit n'ayez pas peur moi je vous dis
ayant confiance merci
merci